hi guys I'm Eric Voss and rogue one a
Star Wars story is now in theaters and
so much about this movie blew me away
but for right now I just want to talk
about one thing in particular the visual
effects and the surprisingly good CGI
that was used to recreate certain
characters from the original Star Wars
film
and obviously I'm about to get into some
major spoilers so you should probably
just go watch rogue one first but
honestly this story and the characters
that I'm gonna talk about have all been
around for like 40 years now so what am
I supposed to not talk about this come
on this is my life this is all I have
okay so rogue one tells a story of the
events that led up to the original Star
Wars a new hope literally catching us up
to the exact moment that Princess Leia
receives the Death Star plans that she
hands off to r2d2 at the beginning of
that movie and I don't know about you
guys but when the opening night audience
that I watch the movie with saw the face
of Princess Leia Carrie freakin Fisher
herself but like 40 years younger
somehow we start freaking minds there
was this massive gasp and no joke I
literally heard someone whisper its
magic it was me I said that I shouted it
actually but the thing is it's not magic
it's just really impressive and probably
super expensive visual effects by George
Lucas's special effects an animation
studio Industrial Light and Magic
so I guess magic was kind of part of it
and obviously rogue one did the same
thing to recreate grand moff tarkin
originally played by Peter Cushing who
died in 1994 as well as the gold leader
and the red leader in the Battle of
scare off' so how did the filmmakers
pull this off it's a complicated process
that uses a mix of body double actors
and computer-generated mapping of
archived footage over the standards face
using motion capture and reanimating it
all to make the facial expressions and
move the lips in a way to make them
speak the new dialogue we a mutant gene
we unlike you and for this to look even
close to authentic you need an actor who
can closely match the original actors
facial structure expressions gestures
just pretty much do the perfect
full-body impression of them and you may
remember the video that we did when a
similar process was used to finish the
late Paul Walker scenes in Fast and
Furious 7
in that case Paul Walker's brothers
stepped in as body doubles and the
finished product was pretty good but
this was not easy to do for Tarkin last
year rumor
from a source close to rogue one called
it one of the most complex and costly
CGI recreations ever now apparently when
George Lucas filmed the first Star Wars
Peter Cushing didn't feel comfortable
wearing the awkward leather riding boots
that the Imperial officers had to wear
and he complained so much that George
Lucas allowed him to wear slippers on
set and he just shot him from the knees
up or from behind the Deathstar
conference table so for Row 1 they
didn't have a lot of footage options to
work with and they had to rely on some
of cushing's previous work on horror
films and by the way that might be why
this version of Tarkin that we saw
briefly in Revenge of the Sith looked
kind of weird so they hired British
actor guy Henry you may remember him as
the corrupt mister of magic in the final
two Harry Potter films or if you're into
BBC Hospital soap operas dr. henrik
henson on Hobie City so this guy has a
very similar long angular face as Peter
Cushing and the way talks is eerily
similar you have nothing to fear and if
you look closely at the Star Wars
Celebration real footage that came out
last summer you can see guy Henry on set
before he was transformed into Tarkin
and in case you were curious that's
actually guy Henry doing Tarkan's voice
a source close to the film actually
confirmed this for us now for Princess
Leia
they used young Norwegian actress in
build Dayla and notice that she has a
strikingly similar round full face and
round eyes that Carrie Fisher had when
she was 20 years old now Dayla hasn't
appeared in much other than a minor role
in Avengers age of Ultron so then it was
a matter of going through hours and
hours of archived footage and using it
all to create 3d animations of Peter
Cushing's and Carrie Fisher's faces to
map over the body doubles rendering them
frame by frame with realistic skin
textures to make it all seamless and in
addition to faster Furious 7 you may
remember this effect being used recently
to make actors look younger like Anthony
Hopkins in Westworld and Robert Downey
jr. in Captain America Civil War
actually Industrial Light magic did the
effects first Civil War - and the
animators on that film talked about how
ayalim has this massive library of image
scans to use as references and knowing
George Lucas that library probably
includes all kinds of footage and angles
and digital remasters he's probably like
I got Annie and George or two of you
guys
okay and rogue one all the effects were
overseen by oscar-winning visual effects
wizard John Knoll of Industrial Light
magic this guy's one of the best he did
all the Star Wars prequels and the
Pirates of the Caribbean movies a ton of
stuff and act it was John Knoll who
originally pitched the initial idea for
rogue one story and obviously a lot of
the success of this movie depended on
Noel's confidence and his team's ability
to authentically recreate Tarkin and
Leia to have that payoff when we see how
this story fits in with the original
Star Wars and according to director
Gareth Edwards after a lot of blood
sweat and tears and no assuring them we
can do this we can do it I think they
pulled it off now Tarkin didn't look a
hundred percent authentic especially the
movement of his mouth but he looked
better than any other time this has been
used and to be honest I couldn't see any
difference at all with Leia and maybe
that's just because as a younger actress
at the time Carrie Fisher had fewer
wrinkles and blemishes on her face a lot
less detail than Peter Cushing had as
Tarkin so it was easier to kind of
recreate that and whether or not this
look believable to you you gotta admit
it ended up being a huge part of what
made robe one so enjoyable that cold
menacing presence of Tarkin as they have
him say and then that closing image of a
young radiant Carrie Fisher saying hope
as the story moves right into a new hope
now I know using old footage like this
can come off as somewhat important
especially when the actor has passed
away as in Cushing's case and some
people are saying this took him out of
the movie a little bit kind of like they
were bringing the actor back from the
dead and it looked a little video game
II and they should have just cast a
similar-looking actor like Genevieve
O'Reily as Mon Mothma
but just to be clear the film did get a
blessing and the rights to use Cushing's
likeness from his family and estate they
also credited Carrie Fisher not sure
about Garvin dreicer John Vander though
and sure it's fair to be concerned about
what this could lead to in filmmaking
like it's possible to get to a point
where every actors past performances are
repurposed and distorted in a way that
they didn't agree to when they initially
signed on to make the film but honestly
so far that hasn't really happened grand
moff tarkin and Princess Leia were
brought back in a specific way by the
same visual effects company to complete
the story as the characters were in the
original film while giving Tarkan's
cruelty even more depth that's not
changing the character and it's
definitely not Greedo shooting first
alright keep an eye out for other rogue
one videos that we're putting out I'm
going to talk
about how exactly robe one story
connects to a new hope and I'm planning
a larger super in-depth breakdown of all
the Easter eggs and references to the
Star Wars universe in this movie because
there were so freaking many it's gonna
take me at least like five screenings to
catch all of them and please hit like
and subscribe to new rockstars and share
this video with your friends also make
sure to click that Bell icon to receive
email notifications when our videos come
out YouTube's been a bit weird about
that lately you can also contribute to
us on patreon thank you so much to all
of our current donors and if you're not
currently a patron that's okay but we
would love your support you can hit me
up on Twitter a TA box with any thoughts
that you had about rogue one or you can
follow a new rock stars on Twitter at
new rock stars for updates on when our
videos are coming out alright thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
[Music]